Today, we'll talk about a very general method called generate and
test. We have looked at knowledge representations like semantic networks.
We'll shift our attention now to problem solving methods. Generate and
test is a problem solving method. This is another item in our
fundamental topics part of the course. The generate and test method in a way,
is very simple. Given a problem, generate potential solutions to it, and
then test the solutions for the efficiency for
addressing the problem. If you had complete knowledge of the world, complete and
correct knowledge of the world. If you had infinite computational resources. And
if you had a method of reasoning that was guaranteed to be correct,
then you can generate the correct, the optimal solution.
You don't need to test it. In general however, you do not have complete or
correct knowledge of the world. You do not have infinite computational
resources, and not all methods are guaranteed to be correct. In that case,
you can generate potential solutions. Plausible solutions,
and then test them. Estimates that will generate, and
test. We will use this method in conjunction with semantic networks, or
the prisoners and guards problem that we discussed last time.